Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, I asked all
of you to submit your Walking Dead Questions
after Episode 11 and I’ve picked 10 to answer
in a video with one fun bonus question.
I’ve also got a new winner to announce in
my weekly Walking Dead Giveaway.
If you’re finding me for the first time
Each week I pick a random subscriber from
the comments to give an amazon gift card to
just as a way to say thank you for being so
awesome.
Round 4 will start when I post my Episode
12 review next Sunday night.
Until then everyone be sure to give Lauriita
Mercury a high five because she is this week’s
winner.
I’ll be messaging you on your channel for
details.
Now let’s answer some mullets.
Questions, I mean questions.
Number 1 - Cameron Peter asks Do you think
Rick and Carl will find out that Judith is
alive soon?﻿
I think they’ll run into Tyreese and Carol’s
group before the season finale, they’re
both headed towards Sanctuary.
I think it will take a few more episodes at
least.
The show is playing this weird trick where
in the comics Sanctuary comes after Alexandria,
so they might be combining those two places
or they might all get to Sanctuary and Leave
early.
I don’t really think they’d combine two
places that had major storylines in the books,
so it will probably be a week or two before
we get a better answer.
Question 2 - Milena Torres asks Do you think
the next episode will be focus on Daryl?
Perhaps showing his past as in the case of
Michonne?
Yes, based on the teaser they’re just going
to cover all the people that they skipped
this week, which is Daryl and Beth and Tyreese’s
Group.
We didn’t get a super deep look into any
of the characters in episode 10.
So the mere fact Daryl and Beth took up the
whole teaser implies that they’ll have the
biggest WTF moment of the episode.
Say your prayers for Beth.
Question 3 - Li Cheng (no avatar) asks Do
you think they ever will make a prequel movie
about the walking dead?
There have been a lot of rumors that the spinoff
tv series that Robert Kirkman is in charge
of is going to be a prequel.
I don’t believe that, but it’s more likely
that they’d tell the prequel bits in comic
book flashbacks.
I don’t really consider the flashbacks that
people on the show like Michonne have to be
prequel storylines.
At least in the way I think you’re implying.
They’re not really going to tell the story
of how the outbreak started.
We’ll definitely learn more about individual
characters before the outbreak though.
Question 4 - George Barrett asks Do you really
think they'd reveal a cure?
No, I don’t think Robert Kirkman will do
that in the comics and I don’t think that
Scott Gimple would do that on the show.
If they did it would automatically create
an endpoint for the series.
Logically curing the outbreak, which would
force the show to end at a certain point.
They will end the main show eventually just
because everyone will get burned out and people’s
salaries will get to expensive.
But Robert Kirkman said he’ll continue making
the comic as long as people keep buying it,
which is basically forever.
And as long as he keeps writing new stories,
the show will have new material to draw from.
The spinoff will be the big test though.
It’s going to be completely new characters
that weren’t in the comics.
If that does well, then you can bet that walking
dead will remain on television in some form
for at least the next 5 years.
Question 5 - Chrocks09 (no avatar) asks Do
you think negan will be introduced this season?
No, or at least if he is.
It won’t be till the final moments.
In the comics he doesn’t debut till way
way later than where they are right now.
So the show would have to skip a lot of stuff
to bring him out.
The Hunters on the other hand are much closer.
They haven’t confirmed them, but I did include
a few more Hunter related questions in this
Q&A.
Question 6 - Ehsan0121 asks Will the whole
group meet up at the end of the season?
The whole group no, but I’m considering
Dary and Beth to be one group, Tyreese and
Carol another, Rick and Michonne are one,
Maggie, Sasha and Bob are one and Abraham
and Glenn make 5 separate groups right now.
By the end of the season I think that at least
two of those groups will merge with others.
I think everyone headed toward Sanctuary will
meet up.
Meaning Rick and Carl will be reunited with
Baby Judith.
And I think that Glenn will find Maggie, meaning
Abraham’s group will merge with hers.
That kind of leaves Daryl and Beth on their
own.
I think it will be a couple more episodes
before we see groups getting closer so it’ll
be easier to make an educated guess on how
it’s going to go down then.
Question 7 - lalov1 asks Do you think the
show will make Abraham seem good to only turn
out to be bad later?
I think Abraham is trying to do good.
I don’t think he’s like the Governor.
He does give off a really aggro vibe, but
it’s really Doctor Mullet we should be worried
about.
He seems too stupid to know anything about
a cure, so keep your eyes on him for any creepy
episode ending smiles.
Question 8 - Jane S (no avatar) asks I noticed
that the bad guy on the porch was Jeff Kober
(who always plays a bad guy).
Do you think that he and any other survivors
of the house will show up later?﻿
Yes, Negan’s group the Saviors have a kind
of biker look to them and he kind of looked
like he was dressed like that.
My first thought was Hunters, but the show
hasn’t confirmed that group will make an
appearance.
So for now I’ll just say yes.
They’ll be back, I just can’t confirm
who exactly they are.
Question 9 - The Turtle Gamer asks do you
think rick or Carl could die this season,
do you think the people in the house could
be a part of a bigger group?﻿
No, but someone from the prison is supposed
to die.
The big rumor is that it’s someone from
the comics who’s still alive in the comics.
I know that sounds weird, but that’s what
the rumor said.
Which really narrows it down, meaning Beth
and Daryl would be safe.
But it puts Maggie on the chopping block potentially.
So cross your fingers and be prepared for
a big WTF.
I think whoever it ends up being, we’ll
be surprised.
I didn’t know what was going to happen to
Herschel in episode 8.
Question 10 - Cristian Hernandez (no avatar)
asks Would go find Maggie or Save the world?
This is the classic Star Trek conundrum, the
needs of the one versus the needs of the many.
Of course I would go save Maggie.
I’m a human being and deeply flawed.
Glenn kind of represents the everyman, like
a totally normal person.
And he’s not going to care about anything
BUT Maggie.
For him it’s not a choice at all.
He was going to smash the shit out of that
window to get them to stop.
It only seems like he’s making a poor choice,
but really I thought he was the only one actually
using his brain.
Even though it seemed like he was only using
his heart.
Bonus Question - teebaby0486 asks The people
in Rick’s House, I got a hunter vibe from
them, but if they're not the hunters who are
they?
The other major group they could be is The
Saviors.
If you want to learn more about them you can
check out the comic books.
But the saviors are associated with Sanctuary
and Negan.
Which is like this big looming threat in the
distance.
I really hope the show doesn’t go there
this fast, it will probably be a couple of
weeks before we get a better picture of how
that’s all going to go down.
There’s at least one more major new character
named Gareth that hasn’t appeared yet.
I’m expecting to see him next week or in
episode 13.
Supposedly he’s going to be a new antagonist
that’s an amalgam of a couple of different
comic book characters.
So thanks so much for submitting your questions.
This was a lot of fun as always.
I tried to combine a few answers since a lot
of you had similar questions.
My episode 12 review and the next round of
the giveaway will post Sunday night after
the episode.
Be sure to subscribe to get it if you haven’t
already.
The olympics are winding down so most tv shows
are back this week, so my schedule should
be back to normal.
And Hannibal is starting on Friday.
So be sure to watch it.
I’ll be doing weekly videos for it.
Right now click here for my episode 11 review
and click here to learn all about the new
companion on Doctor Who.
Thanks for watching, high fives.
See you guys tomorrow!